et avec nous ce soir jacques smith
délégué national uni union nationale
inter universitaire et pascal bouchard
journaliste auteur et spécialiste des
questions d'éducation bonsoir messieurs
et merci d'être avec nous sur rt france
le gouvernement s'efforce donc de
maintenir le calendrier scolaire les
épreuves anticipées du bac vont donc
être remplacé par du contrôle continu
mais pas d'allongement prévu à des
vacances de février à ce stade
l'argument du gouvernement est le
suivant ne pas trouver les familles et
les élèves est ce que vous entendez
cet argument pascal bouchard jean todt
ministre qui fait ce qu'il peut
je ne sais pas trop ce que je ferai à sa
place je ferais sans doute pas mieux
sans doute personne ne ferait ce qu'on
peut lui reprocher ce n'est pas tant les
mesures prises que le style habituel
c'est-à-dire je sais je décide
il a au ministère un parlement de
l'éducation qui s'appelle conseil
supérieur de l'éducation qui est
régulière toute la société sils associés
à ces décisions elle passerait mieux
soient les décisions prises n'ont rien
de scandaleux on y reviendra sans doute
parce qu'elle marque une une tendance à
la une nouvelle réforme du baccalauréat
mais ce n'est pas encore là c'est un peu
ce sont un peu des plans sur la comète
il fallait oui mais non annulé cette
épreuve anticipée du bac prévues au mad
max jacques smith ce qui est clair c'est
que le constat qu'on pourrait faire dès
l'année dernière avec les chiffres du
bac 2020 qui passait de 88 % à près de
96 % de réussite
aujourd'hui les annulations de ces
épreuves de spécialité cette annonce qui
vient de tomber est un coup dur un coup
dur sur la reconnaissance du mérite
ces lycéens est un coup dur sur le le
peu de reconnaissance et encore avoir
malheureusement à cet envers cette cette
institution du baccalauréat et
malheureusement ce bac le rêve encore
être bradés et bat encore être
complètement dégradée parce que c'est
votre sentiment pascal bouchard le bac
2021 les conditions d'obtention de ce
bac évolué de fait est ce que cela
signifie que ce sera en bacs 2021 au
rabais je ne le pense
e en fait je n'en sais rien je ne suis
pas sûr que cela ait beaucoup de sens
en 1968 et je suis un peu plus âgés
n'ont d'autre que mon interlocuteur
j'en ai quelques souvenirs j'avais 18
ans à l'époque le bac 68 a été bradée
donné on a fait ensuite des études
sociologiques pour voir ce qu'étaient
devenus ces bacheliers 68 c'est pas joli
qui avait eu le bac
contrairement à toutes les attentes à ce
qui aurait dû se passer dans un système
normal ils ont tout à fait bien réussi
dans leur vie qui a suivi par ce qui est
clair c'est qu'on va vers un
baccalauréat qui sera simplement un
certificat d'études secondaires qui
prouvera que des jeunes sont allés
jusqu'au bout de leur classe de
terminale qui l'ont suivi honnêtement le
recours qu'ils ont fait à peu près le
travail qu'on leur demandait et puis
qu'ils ont un niveau correct et pour
l'entrée à l'université on voit bien la
logique qui se met en place avec
parcours sur ce sera une logique de tri
pour l'instant sur dossier non pas sur
examen
ça peut changer on va vers cette logique
c'est tout à fait évident c'est dans le
sens de l'histoire
ce serait un peu vous m'amenez une
position un peu paradoxal parce que je
suis l'auteur d'un livre dans lequel je
compare jean michel blanquer à attila
destructeur de notre école donc vous
mettez dans une position paradoxale où
je défends mais je constate qu'il est
simplement dans le sens d'une longue
histoire
malgré des cris d'orfraie
des pour et des contres qui se
chamaillent mouvement était gay vient
alors justement puisque vous évoquez à
l'instant parcours sup le ministre de
l'éducation a indiqué que la plateforme
qui devait donc intégrer les notes des
épreuves de marque ça prendrait en
compte les moyennes et appréciations
portées lors des deux premiers
trimestres
changer les règles en cours de route est
ce que c'est pas carrément déstabilisant
pour les pour les élèves comment est-ce
qu'ils ont réagi à cette annonce jacques
smith mais il faut vous pointer le doigt
là où il faut c'est clairement
l'impréparation du gouvernement
l'impréparation de jean michel bloc'h
visiblement plus intéressés par une
potentielle candidature aux régionales
plutôt que l'avenir de notre jeunesse et
donc l'avenir de notre pays
je réagis ce qu'a dit notre cher
professeur
je trouve ça dommage de prendre l'année
1968 dommage même même peut-être
coupable de prendre l'année 1938 comme
exemple pour l'éducation et pour
l'enseignement supérieur puisque comme
tout le monde le sait c'est une année
désastreuse et qui a mené à une
idéologie qui encore aujourd'hui marque
quelque chose de très mal pour pour
notre pays mais en tout cas pour revenir
très concrètement sa marque
l'impréparation gouvernement aujourd'hui
on voit que c'est d'être un de
spécialités sont supprimés ce qui veut
dire que le baccalauréat sion saura /
contrôle continu il nous propose qu'il y
ait des zorro d'organiser quilles et des
devoirs sur table d'organiser pourquoi
j'ai envie de vous dire pourquoi ne
peut-on pas organiser ses ongles ses
devoirs sur table et ses épreuves de
spécialité en présentiel lorsque les
écoles elles mêmes sont ouvertes et
lorsque les lycées sont ouverts en
présentiel
il y à un paradoxe ce n'est pas normal
de supprimer cette trêve de spécialité
et donc de jeu continue et je persiste
et je signe de mal heureusement brader
ccc et donc il faut bien comprendre que
tous aient tous les lycéens qui vont
ensuite arrivés dans l'enseignement
supérieur sont arrivés avec un gros
déficit et devront je le rappelle
s'adapter au niveau que demande
l'enseignement supérieur et l'université
française
en distance yale sûrement donc c'est un
double comment dire c'est un double
double désavantage crucial est cruelle
pour cette génération qui pour nous est
clairement sacrifier une forme
d'injustice c'est un déséquilibré créé
notamment dans les classes préparatoires
puisqu'on le sait en toute l'année à
l'est les notes sont extrêmement sévères
pour les préparer au mieux aux examens
de fin d'année
est ce que c'est une forme d'injustice
pascal blanchard est ce que les
enseignants notamment où on aurait le
temps de s'adapter et proposer autre
chose en vue de l'évaluation finale
je ne pense pas qu'ils aient le temps de
s'adapter et proposer autre chose
la seule chose qu'ils peuvent faire
c'est comme le ministre d'improviser au
jour le jour en fonction d'une épidémie
qui est assez surprenante et qui placent
dans des gens dans des conditions
difficiles
encore une fois vous mettez dans la
situation de défendre jean michel
blanquer
je considère comme le plus mauvais des
ministres de l'éducation depuis très
très longtemps mais ils improvisent et
n'importe quel ministre improvise rey à
sa place maintenant il y a deux choses
qui sont importantes
la première c'est que il décide de façon
autoritaire comme si nous étions dans
l'amérique de train ou dans la russie de
poutine ou dans je ne sais quel système
autoritaire alors qu'il dispose d'un
parlement d'éducation qui me permettrait
d'associer à ces décisions à la
difficulté de les prendre
l'ensemble du corps enseignant et même
au delà du corps enseignant l'ensemble
de la communauté éducative y compris les
lycéens y compris les étudiants y
compris les parents d'élèves y compris
les élus de la république
donc il y a quelque chose qui ne va pas
dans le mode de prise de décision mais
ce mode de prise de décision les
décisions elles mêmes sont sans doute
lee
évitables et puis elles vont dans un
sens très très profond qu'on peut
regretter je comprends bien que en
interlocuteur les regrette
mais ce sens de l'histoire c'est le
contrôle continu le bac qui devient un
certificat de fin d'études secondaires
et une sélection à l'entrée de
l'université
on n'y coupera sans doute pas c'est ce
qui est en train de se mettre en place
jacques snes quelle ligne claire sur le
calendrier scolaire jean michel blanquer
pourrait-il donner et qu'ils puissent
rester fixe malgré l'évolution de
l'épidémie
sauf que le calendrier scolaire c'est
une chose mais il faut surtout dire et
le dire haut et fort ça fait il faut
bien le dire a dit moir et bientôt un an
mais c'est horrible mais ça fait un an
qu'aujourd'hui on sait qu' il y à la
crise sanitaire
il y a les impacts de cette crise
sanitaire sur l'enseignement supérieur
sur l'éducation
jean michel lambert et l'ensemble du
gouvernement aime bien communiquer sur
le fait que c'est la fierté française de
laisser ouvrir c'est c'est de laisser
ouvert pardon c'est ces écoles et lycées
eh bien il faut aller jusqu'au bout et
faire en sorte que si vous proposez
et si vous permettez cse présentiel
durant les cours il faut permettre aux
devoirs sur table et peut-être mettre en
oeuvre et ça fait encore un nom qu'il
fallait ça fait depuis un autre est ce
que pareil depuis que depuis des mois
qu'il fallait se préparer et on l'avait
on l'avait on avait interpellé le
ministère là dessus que il faut se
préparer la rentrée 2020 on la savait en
septembre très plus y aller très
stratégique puisque il vient c'était en
pleine crise sanitaire et qu'il fallait
s'adapter à cette crise
et bien malheureusement ce n'a pas été
fait donc il faut que le ministre jean
michel blanquer
sache que la jeunesse dans son ensemble
et pas que les lycéens attendent du
ministère et de l'ensemble du
gouvernement des mesures fortes
notamment sur les universités
qu'amoureux 1-1 tout un plan de de
réouverture de saisie rester puisque la
détresse est immense et l'impact va être
immense pour cette génération qui encore
une fois sacrifié donc la jeunesse de
france attend de vous une
des mesures claires et un intérêt qui
devrait normalement être du bon sens
puisqu'il en va de l'avenir de notre
pays
merci beaucoup mais si on aura
l'occasion de d'aborder à nouveau cette
thématique jacques smith délégué
national de l'union nationale
inter-universitaire pascal bouchard
journaliste auteur et spécialiste des
questions d'éducation merci à tous les
deux et à bientôt